on passe donc à ce second thème de sens
public consacré aux nouvelles ordre
mondial la guerre en Ukraine rebat les
cartes le multirate latéralisme et
fragilisé de nouvelles alliances
apparaître et le bras de fer entre la
Chine et les artistes n'est jamais loin
évidemment Jonathan Dupriez
plus de 10 mois de guerre en Ukraine les
10 mois qui ont vu l'ordre mondial
basculer dans une nouvelle ère - diviser
qu'attendu l'Occident a finalement fait
bloc face à la Russie avec en chef de
fil les États-Unis de l'administration
Biden à coup de rallonge budgétaire les
milliards américains ont afflué sans
discontinué pour financer la guerre en
Ukraine faisant naturellement de
Washington l'Allier numéro 1 de Kiev
jusqu'à présent les Russes se sont
engagés seuls alors que vous les
Ukrainiens vous ne l'êtes pas vous avez
reçu une aide significative nous n'avons
jamais été seul vous ne serez jamais
seul dans le sillage des Américains
l'Union européenne affichait aussi un
visage d'unité face à l'invasion russe
en témoigne les sanctions économiques
sans précédent adoptées par l'UE au
lendemain de la guerre comme la
souligner Emmanuel Macron nous avons
apporté une réponse unie rapide et forte
en imposant des sanctions massives et
inédites à la Russie en gardant notre
unité
en bannissant de nos démocraties les
organes de propagande du Kremlin et en
actant le pas historique de l'octroi du
statut de candidat à l'Ukraine et la
Moldavie sous le feu des critiques avant
la guerre l'OTAN a trouvé une nouvelle
raison d'être devenue la garantie de
sécurité de nombreux États limitrophes
de la Russie l'Alliance atlantique et
même en passe de s'étendre à nouveau en
intégrant prochainement la Finlande et
la Suède oui
96% des citoyens de l'Union européenne
une part plus importante que jamais de
son territoire un infra échelle
si l'Occident avance dans le même sens
face à Moscou la Chine joue sa carte
diplomatique en solitaire l'exemple
ukrainien a raviver les velléités
d'expansion de la Chine sur l'île de
Taïwan protégée par les États-Unis la
Chine qui n'a pas condamné l'invasion en
Ukraine continue de soigner ses liens
économiques et même militaires avec
Moscou qui le lui rend bien nous avons
les mêmes points de vue sur les causes
le et la logique de la transformation en
cours du paysage géopolitique mondial la
guerre en Ukraine a aussi fait émerger
des États à la position diplomatique
ambiguë la Turquie membre de l'OTAN a
condamné l'invasion russe mais c'est
montrer très conciliantes envers les
investisseurs du pays pourquoi tourner
les sanctions occidentales aussi le
président herdoine rêve-t-il de devenir
l'arbitre du conflit entre Moscou et qui
est
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités Christian Combon bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes président de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées au Sénat
évidemment sénateurs du Val-de-Marne
Sylvie matedi bonsoir bienvenue à vous
aussi économise directrice adjointe de
l'Institut de relations internationales
et stratégiques l'iris et puis ce livre
géopolitique de l'économie 40 fiches
illustrées pour comprendre le monde
publie aux éditions Eyrolles Bertrand va
dit bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue à vous
vous êtes professeur émérite des
universités à Sciences Po Paris auteur
de vivre de culture comment peut-on
naître franco-persant aux éditions Odile
Jacob Laetitia cruppa évidemment est
resté à mes côtés on voilà on démarre
évidemment et puis on va élargir de plus
en plus le spectre sur cette guerre en
Ukraine Christian Cambon à quel point
elle est en train de rebattre les cartes
de la diplomatie mondiale
je crois personnellement que nous sommes
à la fin d'un cycle ainsi que est en
train de se refermer celui qui était né
au lendemain de la guerre de 1939-1945
et qui avait inscrit dans les faits la
domination de deux grandes puissances
les États-Unis et la Russie qui se
partagaient le monde la guerre froide
après arrive la chute du mur de Berlin
qui est déjà un premier signal que les
choses vont bouger et je crois que
maintenant les logiciels se remettent à
zéro parce que ce cycle étant passe de
se terminer cela vient d'être dit
l'émergence de puissance nouvelle le
fait qu'un certain nombre de valeurs qui
fondaient la vie internationale le
multilatéralisme le rôle de l'ONU et du
Conseil de sécurité dont on entend
quasiment plus parler voilà des éléments
qui viennent perturber qui viennent
perturber la vie internationale et
maintenant on a affaire à des états
puissances qui mettent en avant et qui
ont comme moteur leur propre intérêt et
le conflit ukrainien est un parfait
exemple de cela je ne crois pas savoir
que l'Ukraine menaçait militairement la
mais l'Ukraine voulait opter pour un
mode de vie
occidental qui ne plaisait pas qui ne
plaisait pas à son grand voisin russe et
donc le grand voisin russe tente de
l'envahir voilà un exemple on peut le on
peut voir aussi avec Taïwan la même
duplication de ce genre de changement de
paradigme de changement de logiciel on
l'évoquera évidemment si lui mateli
fasse au sanctions économiques on voit
que la Russie a trouvé des des alliés en
Asie en Afrique oui et c'est intéressant
les sanctions et je vais peut-être
revenir sur ce que vous dites parce que
moi je suis économiste et la fin du
cycle c'est la fin de la guerre froide
des années 90 avec finalement des
populations qui aspirent à autre chose
qu'à cette confrontation d'État qui a
cette guerre froide qu'on a connu et je
suis pas sûr que ce qu'on observe
aujourd'hui alors bien évidemment il y a
la guerre en Ukraine qui nous questionne
et qui vend dans le sens de ce que vous
dites qui va complètement dans le sens
de ce que vous dites mais en même temps
il y a plein d'autres choses qui se
passent partout dans le monde et qui
peut-être
que on est dans la poursuite et un
rééquilibrage de ce cycle qui s'est
entamé dans les années 90 alors avec des
défenses contradictoires moi je suis pas
certaine non plus que la confrontation
des puissances et l'affirmation des
puissances aujourd'hui ce ne soit pas
une forme de réaction par rapport à
cette évolution du monde qui s'est
ouverte il y a une trentaine d'années
que ce soit pas alors j'en sais rien pas
forcément nouvelle ordre mondial là
depuis un an vous il y a une forme de
compte vous trouverez une forme de
continuité
je me questionne est-ce que c'est une
rupture ou est-ce que c'est une forme de
continuité une amplification de tendance
qu'on observe déjà depuis plusieurs
années et les sanctions de ce point de
vue c'est extrêmement intéressant parce
qu'au fond la réponse qu'on trouvait les
Européens et les Américains et leurs
alliés à cette guerre ça a été de
sanctionner ça a été finalement la
dimension économique
l'instrumentalisation de l'économie et
de la mondialisation plutôt que la
guerre et le conflit militaire en
estimant probablement à juste titre que
ce serait plus efficace que
l'intervention sortir on savait les
risques qui étaient pris au niveau
militaire alors bien évidemment les
Russes essayent de s'en sortir essaye de
minimiser l'effet de ces sanctions c'est
difficile aujourd'hui de savoir quels
sont les effets de ces sanctions en
Russie on verra probablement ça si un
jour la guerre se termine mais il est
clair que la conséquences économiques
pour la Russie de cette guerre sont au
moins et je dis bien au moins aussi
dramatique que les conséquences
militaires regardez la fuite des jeunes
la fuite des cerveaux
Bertrand m'a dit depuis 11 mois c'est
pas la troisième guerre mondiale
heureusement mais c'est une guerre
mondialisée je veux bien que vous nous
expliquiez cette idée ce concept oui
vous savez c'est très difficile de
répondre à la première question que vous
posez c'est un sujet un traitable parce
que nous ne vivons pas dans un monde
nous vivons dans deux mondes nous vivons
dans le monde ancien qui régit la
plupart des politiques étrangères d'État
et qui conduit je dirais les plus
conservateurs des dirigeants de la
planète comme Monsieur Poutine à se
lancer dans une guerre de conquête
en quelque sorte une guerre une guerre à
l'ancienne comme il y a du chocolat à
l'ancienne et cette guerre de conquête
elle a mis trois semaines pour échouer
c'est-à-dire que
cette vieille représentation des
dynamiques naturelles autrefois des
relations internationales a été mise en
échec et a été mise en échec d'abord par
une résistance sociale c'est-à-dire il y
a une appropriation sociale de la
conflictualité mondiale qui est un
élément extrêmement nouveau par rapport
à ce que nous avons connu autrefois pas
seulement en Ukraine parce que ça
désigne d'abord cette extraordinaire
résistance sociale ukrainienne mais ça
désigne aussi la posture de la société
russe donc on ne sait pas bien vers quoi
elle évolue et celle des sociétés
européennes alors
cet ancien ordre et puis on a à nouveau
à côté voilà et alors il y a ce hiatus
permanent entre une des politiques
étrangères qui reposent sur des concepts
périmés la puissance depuis 1945 elle
n'a réussi nulle part
les plus puissants ont été mis en échec
partout au Vietnam en Afghanistan
Afghanistan ont autant l'URSS que les
États-Unis dans le Sahel tout ça vient
de quoi vient de la décolonisation qui a
complètement inversé on va pas pouvoir
remonter celui-là mais je voudrais que
vous répondiez à la question sur
la guerre mondiale
c'est justement une guerre qui vient se
greffer sur un monde totalement nouveau
qui est celui de la mondialisation et ça
veut dire quoi la guerre mondiale c'est
l'entrée en guerre successives de toute
une série d'états plus ou moins proche
du foyer initial du conflit ce qui s'est
passé premier à la Seconde Guerre
mondiale la guerre mondialisée ça veut
dire une guerre par irradiation et cette
irradiation elle est double elle est
d'abord sectorielle c'est-à-dire que à
peine cette guerre militaire commençait
elle est devenue sociale comme Jésus
tout à l'heure elle est devenue
économique est devenue énergétique elle
est devenue alimentaire elle deviendra
peut-être économique et monétaire bon
irradiation par secteur irradiation
géographique c'est-à-dire dès février
ce conflit Russo ukrainien dès le 24
février inquiété en Zambie en Corée en
au Sénégal le président du Sénégal
président de l'Union africaine c'est
précipiter en Russie pour discuter de
ces questions allez vous dire
c'est-à-dire que
l'irradiation a été autant géographique
que sectorielle maintenant nous ne
savons pas c'est totalement inédit il y
a pas de précédent nous ne savons pas ce
qu'il peut en sortir peut-être que cette
guerre par irradiation c'est la forme
nouvelle de la dissuasion alors on va
continuer dans débattre évidemment mais
c'est une des images du jour que je vous
propose un Vladimir Poutine qui
persévère lors d'une réunion publique il
apostrophe son vice-premistre sur des
histoires de contrat avec des
entreprises regardez
l'Ukraine mais aussi d'anciens pays de
ce que l'on appelait le bloc de l'Est
depuis 11 mois ça fait 11 mois le début
de ce conflit bah ça fait déjà commencé
mais ils ont tourné le dos est-ce qu'on
peut dire définitivement je ne sais pas
mais le dos à la à la Russie est-ce que
c'est on va parler un peu de l'Europe
c'est une chance ou un cadeau pour ou un
cadeau empoisonné pour l'Union
européenne
je pense évidemment que le fait qu'un
certain nombre de pays de l'Aix en
pierre soviétique ce soit résolument
tourné vers l'Europe c'est quand même un
signe que quelque part nos valeurs qui
sont remises en question dans de très
nombreux pays et l'ordre mondial s'en
trouve bien bouleversé mais c'est quand
même une espérance pour nous et c'est un
pays l'Ukraine qui paye cher cette
volonté car il aurait peut-être très
bien pu rester dans une espèce de magma
un différencier or voilà un pays qui
veut vivre à l'occidental et ça les
Russes ne le supportent pas et les
Russes plaquent dessus une version
absolument invraisemblable disons il
s'agit d'un pays où il y a 44 millions
de nazis et on va y mettre un terme bon
tout ceci n'est pas crédible et je pense
que maintenant tout le monde a bien
compris qu'il y avait effectivement le
début d'un conflit du siècle dernier
c'est à dire j'ai la puissance où je
crois la voir où je crois là parce qu'il
y a eu cette démonstration en quelques
quelques semaines et comme je suis
monsieur et je suis monsieur Poutine à
qui on dit pas la vérité donc je ne sais
pas ce qui va se passer et en fait on
lui dit mais rappelez-vous au mois de
février y compris en Occident le nombre
de gens qui pensaient que ça allait
durer 8 jours et que l'Ukraine serait à
genoux et qu'on en parlerait plus
d'ailleurs c'est la première stratégie
de l'armée russe je pense que le
président Poutine pensait vraiment que
d'abord l'Europe allait explosé en vol
et que on continuerait comme avant
acheter du gaz et avoir des des
attitudes comme celles qu'on a eu sur la
Crimée sur la Tchétchénie sur de
nombreux sur de nombreux conflits la
Transnistrie n'intéressait personne
personne ne sait ce qui s'y passe et
pourtant absolument invraisemblable que
ce pays voit un tiers de son territoire
qui est littéralement déjà sous
domination russe donc les choses sont en
train de de changer maintenant sur la
situation de l'Europe mais je pense
qu'on aura l'occasion d'en parler on
pense que là aussi il y a un cycle qui
se referme je pense que l'Europe a eu
quatre siècles d'avance depuis la
Renaissance et que tout ça est en train
de se terminer et que l'on est en train
de de devenir soit un grand marché de
consommateur ça c'est pour les Chinois
ou bien des alliés des alliés
automatiques moi je raconterai l'épisode
au Congrès américain il y a un mois
lorsque j'ai accompagné le président de
la République je vous assure que ce que
j'ai entendu de la part des congrès
semaines est absolument incroyable
c'est-à-dire que quand il vous disent
quand on va se confronter à la Chine
bien sûr vous êtes derrière nous on dit
écoutez c'est peut-être pas aussi simple
que ça commence là mais en fin de quoi
parle-t-on et donc je crois que l'Europe
qui a commis beaucoup d'erreurs à
commencer par le brexit va devoir se
renforcer sinon on va devenir la vieille
dame incontinent où on peut écouler
quand même des marchandises ça sert à
quelque chose effectivement Laetitia
vous posez la question de la place de
l'Europe dans ce nouvel ordre mondial
exactement dans le prolongement de ce
que vous venez de dire parce que avec
cette guerre en Ukraine on a un peu
hâtivement à mon sens un décrété que la
défense européenne vous avez ce serpent
de mer ce fantasme né de tout de suite
après la création de l'Union européenne
après la deuxième guerre mondiale
finalement ça y est a été créé était là
l'Europe était enfin unie l'Europe
pouvait enfin parler d'une seule voix
il me semble que c'est plus compliqué
évidemment un peu plus compliqué que
cela alors c'est vrai on va commencer
par les points positifs par exemple les
27 sont d'accord sur un point il voit
tous la Russie comme une menace ça a été
dit par le Parlement européen qui a
classé la Russie comme un état promoteur
du terrorisme la Russie qui a réagi en
lançant une cyberattaque contre le
Parlement donc il faut bien comprendre
que l'Europe est aujourd'hui déjà dans
un conflit hybride avec la Russie et
devra coordonner ses réponses alors
c'est un peu commencé mars dernier il y
a un premier document qui s'appelle la
boussole stratégique livre blanc pour la
défense européenne exactement c'est un
document qui qui place une qui installe
une feuille de route et des objectifs
très concrets à atteindre d'ailleurs
d'ici la fin de l'année donc vous voyez
c'est assez immédiat par exemple il faut
trouver un encore sur les modalités
d'opération de sécurité aériennes ou
lancer des exercices communs dans dans
tous les domaines et si les 27
réussissent à mettre en oeuvre cette
feuille de route cela pourrait
constituer c'est vrai un premier pas de
l'Europe en tant qu'ETA face au super
puissant mais quand même Thomas ça c'est
quand même la petite nuance que je dois
apporter depuis le 1er janvier c'est la
Suède qui après et qui a pris la
direction du Conseil de l'Union
européenne
je vous rappelle que elle a sa tête dans
sa coalition l'extrême droite qui est
extrêmement heureux sceptique et puis
aussi la Suède comme beaucoup d'autres
États européens est entré dans l'OTAN
qui joue un rôle crucial finalement dans
la dissuasion et la défense territoriale
donc il faut à mon sens absolument
repenser la défense de l'Europe avec
l'OTAN et c'est pour ça que je vous
rejoins monsieur bien que Joe Biden
laisse entendre comme ça un coulisse que
finalement cette guerre au Vieux
Continent de la régler on voit bien
qu'il aide et qu'il apporte énormément
des milliards de dollars à l'Ukraine et
donc il prend part au conflit et donc
quand on voit aussi le rapprochement de
la Grande-Bretagne avec son nouveau
Premier ministre le rapprochement de la
Grande-Bretagne qui est sorti de
l'Europe mais qui quand même tente à se
rapprocher on comprend que l'axe
démocratique
occidental qui est porté par les angles
au Saxon qui est porté par les
États-Unis et par la Grande-Bretagne
qu'on le veuille ou non reste le modèle
qui prime aujourd'hui pour terminer
l'Allemagne avait profondément accroché
à l'OTAN aussi
de chancelier allemand doit présenter
dans les prochains jours là qui arrive
ça stratégie de sécurité gouvernementale
et elle donnera le la de la défense
européenne pour l'instant c'est clair
l'Allemagne a choisi par exemple dans
son industrie de défense d'acheter 35
avions d'origine américaine voilà il
faudra attendre le prochain conseil
des ministres franco-allemands qui se
tiendra le 22 janvier prochain pour
comprendre comment le moteur
franco-allemand déjà fonctionne ben
est-ce qu'il est toujours crucial pour
réussite enfin à lancer cette défense
européenne en fait la question qui se
pose Thomas ce soir est simple est-ce
que l'Europe peut se positionner comme
un état un état puissant face au super
puissances que sont la Russie les
Etats-Unis la Chine est-ce que les
divergences politiques et économiques
qui persistent entre les 27
ne mettent pas en péril l'état Europe
suivi Matei votre avis
ce conflit finalement en a eu le
sentiment au début d'une Europe en
capacité de réagir vide de montrer une
forme de effectivement de d'union et de
réactivité qu'on lui connaissait pas
est-ce que au fur et à mesure que le
conflit dur cette impression c'est
Filoche alors moi je trouve pas mais
c'est vrai que ben on est toujours dans
la logique européenne où on a 27 États
autour de la table où il négocier ou les
choses sont donc beaucoup plus lentes et
beaucoup plus compliquées que que quand
on est les États-Unis avec une
administration et des responsabilités
bien identifiées ça c'est une certitude
ce que ce que j'observe quand on parle
avec des européens ou quand on regarde
ce qui se passe à Bruxelles ce que
j'observe c'est que des mots qui étaient
tabous il y a quelques années et vous en
avez cité quelques uns monsieur le
sénateur comme la notion de puissance la
notion de d'autonomie ou autre ne le
sont plus aujourd'hui c'est à dire on
arrive à évoquer des sujets on arrive à
discuter de sujets y compris la question
de la politique industrielle et la
politique industrielle de défense qui
aurait été totalement balayé d'un revers
de main par les trois quarts des
Européens il y a quelques années en nous
expliquant non mais attendez vous avez
rien compris c'est pas comme ça que ça
fonctionne etc donc déjà ça commence par
ça la boussole stratégique dont vous
avez parlé c'est quand même la capacité
des Européens à un moment donné assez
rapidement d'ailleurs à se mettre
d'accord sur les menaces auxquelles est
conf l'Europe je peux vous assurer qu'il
y a ne serait-ce que 50 ça vous auriez
mis autour de la table uniquement des
Polonais des Français des Allemands vous
seriez jamais tombé d'accord sur les
menaces auxquelles on était confrontés
donc on voit que les choses bougent il
est évident qu'on est dans une
intégration on n'est pas dans un pays
donc là effectivement et donc un vrai
service à l'Europe vous êtes aussi
affirmative que ça mais oui mais bien
sûr mais bien sûr pourquoi
aussi rassemblée et c'était bien sûr
moi je ne le crois pas je ne crois pas
je vois beaucoup de dirigeants européens
au Sénat et je pense et je pense au
contraire que la prise en compte du
danger russe a réuni beaucoup de pays
d'Europe l'affaire de la Finlande et de
la Suède leur entrée à l'OTAN et est
absolument spectaculaire le 1er janvier
donc vous dites vous dites finalement
oui il y a une
oh franchement alors vous êtes si vous
êtes dubitatif je le disais pourquoi oui
moi je pense que les choses sont
infiniment plus complexes et incertaine
que cela parce que il faut avoir en tête
une triple contradiction la première
contradiction elle vient des États-Unis
bienheureux et seul ou celui qui peut
définir ce qu'est la politique étrangère
des États-Unis aujourd'hui qui sont pris
dans une contradiction très rude très
forte entre un messianisme qui les
conduit à un leadership auquel ils n'ont
jamais renoncé et une société américaine
qui est en pleine fièvre protectionniste
et même isolationniste qui considère
qu'on a beaucoup trop dépensé en
intervenant à l'extérieur et qui
rappelez-vous les murmures à la Chambre
des représentants au moment de cette
fameuse élection de Monsieur McCarthy
toute cette elle républicaine qui
faudrait quand même s'interroger sur une
continuité
qui fait que d'ailleurs le fameux reset
de la politique étrangère américaine par
Biden n'a jamais été établi la deuxième
contradiction c'est que l'Europe
effectivement fait valoir parce que en
politique la rhétorique ça compte
beaucoup
elle a un projet de défense etc mais
fondamentalement l'Europe est attachée à
l'idée d'un parapluie américain parce
que financièrement et budgétairement
c'est quand même vous direz mais elle y
a tout intérêt donc c'est pas
incompatible mais si c'est une
contradiction parce que quand il s'agit
de faire le saut saut bien entendu pour
passer du côté de l'autonomie de défense
là cette question se pose alors vous
aurez la troisième contradiction après
mais pourquoi pas d'accord
tout ça allez-y si vous voulez bon
est-ce que vous voulez pas au contrat de
dire être au contracteur maintenant vous
le serez plus tard allez-y
infiniment contradiction merci monsieur
le Président soyez certain que c'est
réciproque la troisième contradiction
c'est que l'Europe elle a une histoire
de 400 ans 500 ans de compétition et les
politiques étrangères en Europe elle se
définissent non pas dans la convergence
mais dans l'opposition et ça c'est un
paramètre qu'il ne faut pas oublier et
si vous regardez décennies de
construction européenne malgré les
décennies de construction européenne qui
visait autre chose faut pas l'oublier
une défense voilà notamment et pas
seulement mais surtout ce qui est très
important c'est que il y a des lectures
antagoniques du rapport entre l'Europe
et l'OTAN si vous prenez l'attitude de
la Pologne ou des États baltes ils ont
dans leur conception d'un rapport à
l'OTAN une option totalement différent
de celle de la partie la plus
occidentale de l'Europe la preuve et je
m'arrêterai là la preuve ça a été
lorsqu'il y a eu ce missile qui s'est
abattu à la frontière polonaise la
Pologne et les Baltes se sont mobilisés
très fortement pour impliquer davantage
l'OTAN dans ce conflit donc
il y a je dirais toute une ventilation
tout un éventail tout un éventail des
positionnements des États européens par
rapport à l'OTAN et donc par rapport aux
États-Unis donc l'affaire n'est pas
jouée est-ce que vous voulez intervenir
maintenant je veux simplement je veux
simplement dire que ce qui explose le
poseur Bailly avec le talon qu'on lui
connaît n'est pas incompatible avec une
analyse qui effectivement laisse à
penser que ce n'est pas incompatible le
retour de l'OTAN souvenez-vous les
propos du président de la République
autant état de mort cérébrale qui
oserait prétendre une chose pareille
puisque maintenant ceux qui n'ont pas le
temps sont malheureusement ceux qui sont
attaqués par la Russie ou qui menacent
ou qui risque de l'être et c'est une
garantie que tout le monde reconnaît la
France du reste
oui peut-être la France du reste au sein
de l'OTAN exerce des responsabilités
absolument essentielles nous nous avons
le commandement s'acti à Norfolk nous
participons à toutes les manœuvres de
réassurance dans les Pays-Bas nous
sommes en Roumanie nous sommes en
Pologne tous les jours nous avons des
rafales qui décollent de Saint-Dizier
pour aller assurer au nom de l'OTAN la
liberté et l'intégrité du ciel polonais
et donc je crois qu'il y a eu il y a
bien sûr la reconnaissance du rôle de
l'OTAN mais il y a la prise de
conscience que la Russie est devenue du
fait de Monsieur Poutine un véritable
danger que le départ des Américains de
Kaboul qui suivaient celui de Bagdad
reste encore dans l'esprit des Européens
moi je vois les dirigeants d'Europe
centrale qui viennent nous voir au Sénat
et qui eux-mêmes sans être sollicité on
parle systématiquement et nous disent il
faut que le couple franco-allemand se
renforce il faut que l'Europe prenne
conscience qu'elle va devoir un jour
peut-être prendre son sort en main et
donc je que tout ne se fait pas d'un
claquement de main que l'Europe de la
défense tout ça reste encore très
conceptuel mais que les choses avancent
c'est que Poutine a aidé à cette prise
de conscience et encore une fois
l'exemple de la Finlande 1er janvier
2022 12% des fins landais disent qu'ils
veulent adhérer à l'OTAN le dernier
sondage 87 % comme dit l'autre chercher
l'erreur comment est-ce que l'OTAN
provoque la Russie non le je pense que
Poutine veut avancer l'idée selon lequel
le temps a provoqué la Russie le temps a
commis à mon sens quelques erreurs enfin
il y a une polémique sur lequel les
historiens vont se prononcer ou
effectivement monsieur James Baker lors
de l'effondrement de l'empire soviétique
prend paraît-il l'engagement que jamais
un pays ne viendra un pays de l'OTAN
deviendra au contact direct des des
frontières russes on sait que les choses
sont passées un peu différemment mais on
pouvait imaginer que ces choses avaient
été admises elle n'était pas du tout
dans l'esprit de qui pour des raisons y
compris de politique intérieure dont on
pourra peut-être dire un mot avance
maintenant pour susciter ce nationalisme
russe qui existe et qui est un des
fondamentaux de l'histoire de ce pays
Sylvie matérielle vous avez évoqué le
brexit le le aussi on parle d'un nouvel
ordre mondial c'est que alors ça c'est
pas c'est pas cette année mais c'est un
affaiblissement de fête de l'Europe et
d'une potentielle défense européenne on
peut dire ça alors c'est assez mitigé
sur le brexit parce que c'est vrai que
ça n'est jamais une bonne nouvelle que
d'avoir un État membre qui s'en va mais
c'était mais c'était quand même un étang
un État membre un peu poil à gratter un
peu fauteur de trouble et je crois que
le changement de discours c'est vrai
qu'on est peut-être encore
essentiellement dans le discours même
s'il y a un certain nombre d'initiatives
qui sont encourageants le changement de
discours à Bruxelles il est quand même
venu à la fois du brexit et de
l'élection de Monsieur Trump
c'est-à-dire il y a eu ces deux chocs
avec le départ d'une d'un pays qui ne
voulait pas d'une Europe puissance qui
s'opposaient à une robe puissance et
puis l'arrivée d'un président aux
États-Unis qui quelque part a questionné
le le côté allié des pays européens qui
a questionné le financement de la
défense européenne et son engagement
dans l'OTAN et donc bien évidemment tout
ça ça a un petit peu secoué les
Européens qui se qui ont commencé à se
questionner et qui n'ont cessé parce que
les crises se sont succédé il y a eu le
brexit il y a eu le covid et puis
aujourd'hui la guerre en Ukraine qui
n'ont cessé de se questionner sur leur
rôle et je crois que au-delà de la seule
défense la question de la puissance et
de la souveraineté européenne elle se
pose par rapport à dans ce monde
fragmenté à un moment donné on va on va
avoir plusieurs choix en fait et les
Européens je crois ont bien conscience
de ça le choix de s'aligner sur les
Américains mais de subir aussi une
politique américaine qui devient plus
protectionniste qui qui défend beaucoup
plus fermement l'intérêt national
américain même si ça a toujours été le
cas mais c'est plus vrai ça sont sur ce
protection ils sont pas ils sont
d'accord sur le protectionnisme ils sont
pas tous d'accord sur l'attitude et ça a
été très bien dit par par Monsieur Badi
sur latitude à avoir vis-à-vis des
Américains mais à côté de ça il y a des
intérêts européens ailleurs il y a des
intérêts allemands des intérêts
économiques et industriels allemands
extrêmement forts en Chine en Chine
économique donc quand vous comparez la
Chine les États-Unis la Russie c'est
rien du tout évidemment il y avait des
intérêts économiques mais c'est pas ce
qui domine quelque part par contre les
intérêts économiques en Chine sont
énormissime Bertrand va dit un mot et
puis ensuite on va parler de la folie il
faut faire très attention au fait que il
n'y a pas que l'hémisphère nord
et qu'il y a les puissances émergentes
qui sont en train de jouer une
diplomatie pivot actuellement et il y a
le grand sud comme on dit or ce qui
m'inquiète c'est que dans ce conflit
Poutine a été battu il a été battu
plusieurs fois mais il est en train ce
qui est extraordinaire du point de vue
des relations internationales de rent
poser ses défaites il rentabilise ses
défaites comment en disant en se
tournant vers le sud et les émergents en
disant je suis la première victime de
l'hégémonie occidentale qu'ils synonymes
de l'OTAN et il apparaît comme si vous
me permettez l'expression avec beaucoup
de guillemets le tribunal de la plèbe
c'est-à-dire de tous ceux qui sont en
situation d'être dominé par l'Occident
et en disant voyez moi je vous
représente et j'ai le courage de
m'opposer à cette hégémonie occidentale
et il y a quand même quelque chose qu'il
faut souligner vous avez eu
53 États qui ont refusé de sanctionner
la Russie alors que tous les États
devraient sanctionner un pays qui a
violé de manière très claire le droit
international c'est une forme d'échec de
la diplomatie américaine et diplométrie
occidentale et c'est là que je voulais
en venir parce qu'elle est regardée au
sud moi je reviens d'Afrique où j'en ai
eu des témoignages multiples elle est
regardée comme une diplomatie de
l'entre-soi et ce conflit
Ukraine Russie qui n'a rien à voir avec
un conflit Est-Ouest qui est le conflit
du droit contre la violence n'est-ce pas
et réinterpréter comme le conflit de ces
deux gladiateurs dont nous avons eu à
subir pendant des siècles et des siècles
à domination et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je crois que l'OTAN a un effet
négatif un effet d'image négatif
puisqu'il cultive cette entre soi dont
nous sommes victimes auprès de tous ces
bricks ces émergents ces pays du Sud
alors vous parliez de l'Afrique
justement je propose à terme traduit de
nous rejoindre sur ce plateau rebons
soit on va parler de l'influence de de
la France certains s'inquiètent
justement de cette perte d'influence en
Afrique et oui l'étoile palie de la
France en Afrique c'est sur ce sujet car
sénateur a hier interpellé le
gouvernement le constat c'est que nous
sommes désormais personne à non grata
dans certains pays d'Afrique dernière
illustration l'ambassadeur de France au
Burkina Faso les aut burkinabé ont
demandé son départ c'est une situation
qui reflète plus largement notre baisse
d'influence selon le sénateur les
républicains huxory écoutez-le hier aux
questions au gouvernement dans cette
partie de l'Afrique où elle a pourtant
tant œuvrer la France est récemment
devenue indésirable malgré l'engagement
de nos militaires contre le terrorisme
islamiste et le sacrifice de 53 d'entre
eux malgré le niveau considérable de
l'aide au développement déployé dans
cette zone prioritaire jamais la France
n'y a été tant critiquée étant rejeté et
en effet la France ex puissance
coloniale est contestée au Burkina Faso
face à cela la secrétaire d'État
chrysola zacharropulu en déplacement
mardi à insisté sur le respect de la
souveraineté du pays je la cite un jeune
suis venu ici influencé aucun choix ni
aucune décision personne ne peut dicter
ses choix au Burkina la France est en
mesure de faire moins ou de faire plus
elle est aussi et surtout capable de
faire différemment dans écoute le
respect l'humilité car c'est une attente
qui est exprimée avec force ici
évidemment ce qui s'est passé au Mali et
dans toutes les têtes et oui après neuf
ans de lutte anti djihadiste les
militaires français ont donc été poussés
de là dehors la France a été jugée
coupable d'un gérance dans les affaires
du pays par la junte et par la
population malienne les dirigeants
maliens ont depuis fait appel aux Russes
via la société paramilitaire Wagner que
l'on ne présente plus les Russes qui
s'étaient lancées en parallèle dans une
guerre de l'information des vidéos
accusant la France de crimes de guerre
avec l'affaire du charnier de Gossip des
fake news des rumeurs qui ont enflé sur
les réseaux sociaux relayés par des
comptes trop russe quant elle a été
interrogée d'ailleurs sur la baisse de
l'influence française en Afrique et bien
Catherine Colonna hier a pour
l'essentiel répondu sur le terrain de
l'information écoutez là
en Afrique comme ailleurs les
manipulations de l'information ne
cessent de prendre de l'ampleur et dans
plusieurs pays la France est visée par
des campagnes des campagnes qui n'ont
rien de spontané on le sait voilà une
allusion donc non voilée aux stratégies
russes sur les réseaux mais la place
l'action les actions de la Russie en
Afrique n'inquiète pas seulement les
Français également les Américains et oui
c'est ce que relate le Wall Street
Journal relayé par l'opinion à propos de
l'Escale secrète d'un navire russe en
Afrique du Sud qui selon le gouvernement
américain a transporté des armes pour le
compte du gouvernement russe et les
journalistes expliquent bien dans leur
récit la situation je cite l'article le
parti au pouvoir en Afrique du Sud
entretient des relations étroites avec
Moscou qui remonte au soutien de l'Union
soviétique dans sa lutte contre la
domination de la minorité blanche comme
de nombreux autres pays africains
l'Afrique du Sud a tenté d'adopter une
position neutre sur la guerre en Ukraine
notez que le mois prochain et bien
l'Afrique du Sud doit accueillir un
exercice conjoint avec les Marines
russes et chinoise la Chine un autre
pays qui étend son influence en Afrique
d'ailleurs le ministre des Affaires
étrangères chinois est en pleine tournée
africaine et hier il a déclaré que
l'Afrique devrait être mieux représentée
au Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU merci
beaucoup tamis pour toutes ces
explications la Chine qui renforce aussi
ses alliances dans les pays du golf dans
les pays arabes on l'a vu notamment
début décembre puisque le président
chinois occidenting était et était pour
une visite assez longue en Arabie
Saoudite je reviens sur la perte
d'influence que Christian Cambon de la
France dans ces pays d'Afrique est-ce
que elle est inquiétante est-ce qu'elle
est pour autant irréversible est-ce
qu'il y a quelles sont les solutions
pour vous
d'abord la présence de la France
n'a pas été que négative et je pense
qu'il faut pas passer par pertes et
profits tout ce qu'on a pu y apporter y
compris sur le plan culturel sur le plan
institutionnel et sur le plan économique
où les intérêts français ont bien sûr
profité aussi au développement d'un
certain nombre de pays je pense mais là
on fait face à une guerre de la
formation bien évidemment l'Afrique est
un continent qui est en pleine mutation
et ça il faudrait parfois qu'on le
comprenne bien et donc un continent qui
devient qui touche une période de sa de
son développement en mutation
intéressent beaucoup d'abord parce que
c'est un continent très riche qui a
beaucoup de réserves beaucoup de
ressources et beaucoup de pays qui
effectivement ont pris la voie j'allais
dire de ce qu'on appelait précédemment
les non alignés c'est-à-dire et là je
rejoins tout à fait le professeur Badi
dans ce conflit nous ça ne nous
intéresse pas on veut être bien avec
tout le monde là-dessus sont arrivés
quand même les Russes qui avec les
ministres Wagner font effectivement et
déclenchent des campagnes
anti-françaises qui sont bien
identifiées on le voit sur les réseaux
la Chine souhaitait de présente aussi
mais est-ce que cette présence russe
arrivera à à faire disparaître
l'influence française personnellement je
ne le crois pas parce que il y a une
dimension culturelle qui reste
importante le français est encore une
des une des langues les plus parlées sur
le continent africain avec me
semble-t-il quelques dangers j'ai les
vues déjà en Algérie ou la pratique du
de l'anglais se multiplie à vue d'oeil
et faudrait aussi faire attention à nos
relations avec le Maroc qui est quand
même cultive la francophonie mais il
faut bien traiter le Maroc je le dis en
tant que président du groupe d'amitié
France Maroc au Sénat il faut faire
attention donc je pense que nous n'avons
pas non plus toujours
investi dans la francophonie comme il le
convenait comme il le fallait donc il y
a des risques évidents je pense que
l'opération du Mali a été trop longue
vous arrivez en conquérant et vous
partez en occupant et trop d'années de
domination avec des effectifs qui de
toute façon n'a
revenir sur la question africaine et et
ce ça pourrait être une voix originale
pour la France je crois que ce qu'on
sous-estime et dont on parle assez peu
et qu'on a assez peu pris à bras le
corps dans cette crise ukrainienne c'est
que au fond chaque fois qu'il y a une
crise qu'elle soit sanitaire qu'elle
soit économique que ce soit une guerre
ce sont toujours les mêmes qui en paye
le prix ce sont toujours les mêmes qui
en payent les conséquences et je crois
que c'est ce que aujourd'hui aussi alors
je suis jusqu'au bout c'était de dire
qui paye le Christ regardez l'Afrique
qui en souffre tout à fait qui en
souffre je suis pas en train de nier la
guerre informationnelle et la guerre
d'influence qui se joue en Afrique
autour de la Russie de la Chine et
d'autres puissances d'ailleurs parce
qu'il y a des intérêts majeurs mais je
crois que au-delà de ça l'une des voies
peut-être pour se
religittimer ou relégitimer notre
présence en Afrique ou en tout cas
redorer notre blason en Afrique ce
serait d'essayer de pense que vivent ces
pays et ce à quoi ils font face eux la
guerre en Ukraine c'est pas la guerre en
Ukraine elle est pas c'est pas
géographiquement parlant la guerre en
Ukraine elle est chez eux c'est des
risques de pénurie c'est des risques de
famine à l'époque du covid c'était une
difficulté d'accès au vaccin contre la
covid etc etc et même au-delà de ça sur
la lutte contre l'inflation si vous
prenez la lutte contre l'inflation le
resserrement des politiques monétaires
en Occident a des conséquences délétères
dans les économies du Sud et dans les
économies des pays du Sud donc c'est par
exemple la question des céréales tout à
fait et
sans en pas seulement bien sûr mais
c'est l'une des questions mais sans en
tenir rigueur la Russie c'est ça que
j'ai dû un peu de mal à comprendre
en fait ils font pas disons que c'est
ils font pas le forcément le lien entre
entre ça et quelque part le les
problèmes de pénurie les questions de
famille etc c'est pas seulement la
guerre en Russie c'est aussi le
réchauffement climatique dont il
considère que nous sommes les principaux
responsables et à raison c'est
réchauffement climatique sur lequel on
leur donne un certain nombre de leçons
en leur expliquant qu'il faut que aussi
ils aillent vers la neutralité et eux
nous explique mais on a besoin d'argent
on n'arrive pas à collecter les fonds
vous voyez il y a tout un ensemble de
d'attitude
encore avec des tendances de domination
et de et de donneur de leçons qui ont de
plus en plus de mal à passer en Afrique
et on les comprend parce qu'ils sont en
train de vouloir prendre en main leur
propre destin Bertrand m'a dit on vous
avait commencé à l’évoquer on a on a
parlé de de la guerre froide c'était
Est-Ouest je me souviens de variée
jusqu'à Dassin qui disait à la fin des
années 70 le nouvel ordre mondial c'est
Nord-Sud là c'est un peu une division
Ouest Sud est-ce qu'on peut dire ça et
est-ce finalement les pays d'Afrique
sont dans la partie sud ce qui semble
logique avec un allié étonnant qui est
la Russie non justement c'est plus que
ça c'est la fin de la géopolitique
c'est-à-dire ces repères classiques Nord
Sud Est-Ouest ça n'a absolument rien il
y a quelque chose de très important qui
se passe et que l'on ne dit pas
suffisamment c'est la fluidification des
relations diplomatiques c'est d'ailleurs
cette façon dont on passe dans les
relations diplomatiques du mariage
institutionnalisé il alliance pérenne à
l'union libre diplomatique c'est-à-dire
un soir avec
Erdogan un soir avec le roi Salman un
soir avec tilling ping un soir avec le
président avec Nathan Yahoo etc donc
chaque pays selon ses intérêts et voilà
mais avec et je rejoins tout à fait ce
qui est dit c'est très important une
montée fulgurante des paramètres sociaux
que nous ne voulons pas voir et c'est
paramètres sociaux font que la guerre au
Sahel c'est plein de choses
c'est bien sûr une partie du terrorisme
mais le terroriste c'est pas la partie
principale de la guerre du Sahel le
Sahel c'est une formidable décomposition
sociale et institutionnelle et croire
que le canon est un remède à la
décomposition sociale et
institutionnelle c'est une naïveté
incroyable donc il faut prendre le
problème à l'envers c'est-à-dire prendre
au sérieux la gouvernance globale
prendre au sérieux les grands orgeuses
sociaux internationaux prendre au
sérieux le fait que les politiques
tutélaires que nous avons menées ce ne
sont peut-être crucelles qui
correspondent aux paramètres
d'aujourd'hui
géopolitique de l'économie 40 fiches
illustrées pour comprendre le monde
s'est aux éditions Eyrolles et Bertrand
m'a dit vivre de culture comment peut-on
naître Franco perçant aux éditions Odile
Jacob je vous dis à lundi bonne soirée
sur Public Sénat Laetitia à très vite à
bientôt à très bientôt votre prochain
rendez-vous politique c'est dans la
matinale Oriano enseigné reçoit
l'ancienne ministre de la Culture
Roselyne Bachelot
[Musique]